hey guys Dennis hear the fan of fig here
and I'm David Griffin your resident
comic book and video game guru and this
is our review of boardwalk empire season
4 episode 9 and marriage and hunting dog
marriages chalky sons getting married
Ben duh of course mr. Harrow yeah that
was a great scene with a Richard Harrow
well first of all he gets proposed to by
his girl and it's not the most romantic
thing no it's basically out of necessity
so that that she has a better chance of
retaining Tommy Jimmy son the judge kind
of hinted at the end he's like he's like
so are you married about marriage and
income with a big two factors about yeah
so I love that Harrow came to Nucky
right and said yeah I need a job he's
the best hit man that he could ever have
and he just like to talk about the
finale last tour that place up and Nucky
needs hitman people now cuz it looks
like he's getting dragged into this war
with dr. Narcisse you know we saw at the
end of last episode with chalky and that
big fight with Don purnsley and and now
dr. Narcisse he knows what's up you know
he knows that Don purnsley showed up and
got killed because you know he's not a
stupid guy and so he took it out on the
singer right and there she says I think
kind of seen those days might be he's
talking smack about chocolate saying his
days are numbered Narcisse days might be
numbered as well I mean hey goes pretty
a desperate move for him to come
confront Nucky at his you know well at
Chalky's club anyway out in public like
that I think he's getting desperate to
yeah and that was a big old you know
mess of stuff cuz he wasn't supposed to
sit there and chalky was going after him
and those are great scene it was just so
many elements going on there with the
comedian making all the racial jokes and
of course at you know African America is
expense and at the same time you know
he's a middle of all that yeah and also
chalky being owner but chalky himself is
not allowed is it there those great and
dr. C's is like you know in in Lucky's
face about it and now yeah Nucky's being
dragged into saying because chalky asked
for help and in the big
nothing went to talk to Eli he know he
wasn't you know he would say they kind
of were were like yeah yeah we don't
want to involve ourselves in which I
don't agree i love chalky and i want to
see him make it out of this but I mean
chalky did kind of get himself in this
little bit he shouldn't have been
smarter should have been messing around
with that girl and you know his head's
always caught up in her and she knows
where she is I mean I think he's he's
kind of dug himself a little hole he'll
granite Narcisse is playing him and
trying to get at him and usurp his power
but I think yeah I mean yeah I think
Chuckie's gotta take care of biz but he
has manpower chalky he has manpower so
he needs to use it yeah well we saw a
little preview right yeah episode some
you know the stuff is good this year is
going down on dad I was like the final
30 episode seems everything goes down
for sure yeah and then speaking of eli
there was that little moment in the
beginning where you I wants he wants
Nucky to tell him what he already knows
about his side yeah but it's it's not
happening right and we you know and also
in the preview we see that the ELA is
working with with the fat yeah yeah that
he agreed to something right is he still
talking if he said no he would have told
Nucky there would you know there would
have been writing some sort of plan and
Shelton but it seems like would you also
see that I think he likes son's gonna
get more involved too I mean we know
that from the previous episode that he's
gonna start slow and build up so Lucy
how that all it's going to work out now
if Eli is supplying information or is he
playing the pheasant who knows what role
of meat is he gonna give in to the feds
and betray Nucky again or who knows yeah
and then also we had what was going on a
lot of a van alden cellular this episode
getting you know he's man this one well
cuz he's you know he's just feeling the
weight and the burden of his family life
and then obviously all the tension with
the work no Virginia and I mean he's
been these just slapped around like all
even slept on so much left Iran you get
the guys beating them up from his old
work you know the whole iron on the face
you have O'Banion slapping around you
have Capone and his brother slapping him
around I mean he's jesus fed up and he
said look I have killed people yeah i
drowned my own partner in front of the
whole church
gregation it's like I will kill you I'm
not afraid of you yeah the real Van
Alden is coming oh he's bad he's good to
his wife said take off your dress and
all that it he's like Who am I I mean he
said oh this is like you know Walter
white man you know is uh was really good
yeah and he's you know obviously now
Banyan is dead yep I don't didn't quite
get if if if Van Alden hired those guys
to kill him right seems like he was
surprised by it so it must have been
kalpa Capone's like back-up plan trusted
him yeah not thinking he's gonna do it
he got his he got his money anyway yeah
he's gonna get that plumbing fixed and
then well you know we had talked about
herro and and Jillian we still don't
know what uh Roy Ron Livingston's
character what his plan is and what his
he obviously has some sort of a altar
plan like a side somebody he's angling
for something but we don't know what it
is yet he's like he's too nice of a guy
to jail and Jalen's Helms all this bad
stuff about her he's very supportive we
don't know why he's there there's a
different reason we have the phone
conversation that we see at the end they
catch him he's like oh it's just
business down in Memphis I mean what's
he really talking about it it has to be
something related to Nucky in her
relationship I mean I can't imagine
she's really done anything that and
portent lately i mean i mean thats
related except her connection to all the
gangsters over the years all the mob
guys it has to be something related that
I would think I don't know any other
reason why he would stick around so long
then also with the kid Tommy her her
grand right on he's he's important to
her he's important to a half face right
arrow and his girl but in the scheme of
things he's not really that important to
it you know no right anyone else so the
vision to see I mean I don't know I get
her stories always been the ones kind of
bothered me i'm not sure why she's still
around yeah i thought it should have
ended last season yeah thought she died
you know from Oh Dean
and then that we wouldn't see her
anymore but she's going to be clean and
sober me that'll be more interested in
the wall to see but I want to talk about
to uh I mean this is a small scene but i
love the moments well I guess couple
scenes with the Rothstein and in this
episode again this see we didn't touch
all the characters in this episode we
got a good amount of characters and i
liked the conversation he had between
his is ma'am i guess his hit man
whatever that guy was you know the guy
works for him and about gambling and how
he's he's he's vulnerable now I mean
before when we first learn the first he
had this confidence because all his life
he'd always want okay family yeah and
now he's not and what that confidence is
is broken it's you know it's it's an
easy way to start losing and he's like
begging for money i mean here comes in
lucky like hey how much will you give me
not to kill your boy here you know and
he says look he's like yeah people would
kill him for free like Mickey Doyle you
can just go ahead and kill Mickey then
they had to make a deal and he like
Rothstein was just so happy he's gonna
get a hundred grand I mean he's that
much in you know how much debt he's in
but and he's in trouble yeah he's not
making that much money no and now his
boys are doing you know Meyer and you
know Lucky Luciano who didn't see this
episode but they're making their own
moves now you know starting to come up
which we know from history that's going
to happen yeah so yeah it just seems
like everything's starting to move now
we're gonna have some sort of war going
on in Chicago Capone wants to get under
the shadow of his boss Torrio banelings
gonna factor into that somehow though we
got this war between chalky and doctor
nurse sees we know this is gonna go
visit lucky Luciano's boss yeah yeah so
we know that's gonna happen so I mean
there's all these pieces are moving
together is gonna be it's gonna be a
battle yeah and it looks like it starts
next week though everything's going down
right and then also the in the preview
we see that Nucky finds out that Meyer
lucky are moving heroin with with the
alcohol down in Florida well this is the
thing with Boardwalk Empire which always
appreciate as we know the ladder final
three episodes are going to be where the
bulk of the action is and you know it
the show can sometimes feel slow but
it's slow with a purpose like you know
what's gonna get somewhere it's like a
big 13 hour movie we talk about walking
dead earlier tonight and that one
sometimes it's slow but it's not so is
it done a payoff now you
Nolan Borg Empire we're gonna get a pass
yeah there's a lot of information a lot
of chess pieces movie but in the end
it's all coming together so I don't know
I'm excited it's gonna be good yeah so
let us know what you think you can post
your comments below on our website thing
caricom or on our youtube channel think
hero pro make sure you subscribe to that
are you also going to tell with us on
twitter check with dennis myself at
think hero i'm at griffin de and we also
have a Facebook page that's facebook.com
slash think hero fans and also make sure
you like that page you know chair are
our video give us like yeah actually
last week one of our viewers Paul he
tweeted our video to uh to michael
kenneth williams just like who plays
chalky and Omar from the wire who's on
Boardwalk Empire and he actually
retweeted it never know who's watching
never know who's watching yeah see i'll
post a picture right here it shows him
retweeting it alright guys thanks
you